yeah I've got I gotta leave one of my
very close friends his house is always
it's very nice but you'll go over there
and you'll be like always very nice like
there's this one time I went over to
someone who's not around anymore but I
went over to my boy's crib
and he had a bunch of tile in his
Workshop
and I was like oh you got a new towel
you know
it's like I know open the top one I
looked down just [__] kilos of
cocaine just stuffed down up [__]
like this in the tiles yeah
scary crazy when I see multiple bricks
rest in peace to that guy too by the way
he passed away
it always gives me a bad feeling yeah
like a feeling of like I need to get out
of this place some there's too much
money in this house and that shit's evil
well and then you get desensitized to it
too oh yeah it's scary too I mean cokeys
be homies and it's just bad for me so I
don't do it anymore I used to cook all
too [__] I've never I've actually
never done any drugs but weed and
shrooms good I'm so happy for you keep
it that way but because I see my family
you know oh yes my dad has a [__]
crank head my whole life and have you
ever done anything like crazy like that
like oh I've done all drugs you've done
it all done it all what's your least
favorite crack crack makes you feel
disgusting I gotta ask you about crap it
makes you it made me feel gross because
ice I watch snowfall right and yeah
snowfall's great what a great show and
like you know you'll those are
crackheads just the way I feel about
crack is it's it's a I mean listen most
serious drugs people are willing to
check their sexuality at the door to get
more of it oh yeah there's like grown
straight men offering [__] in
America right now for more crack or
fentanyl for sure for sure right so my
thing is it's like well crack must be
amazing oh you're talking about the Dr
oh I haven't done heroin or acid but
crack crack everyone all right look at
when I smoked it with my Uncle John he
passed away recently that fool was like
my best homie and
I got him to do Coke for the first time
in his life and he's 11 years older than
me so here I am 15 we smoke weed all the
time together
and I'm like hey man he's like I'll
never put powder in my my nose but he
was smoking crack no he'd never do
anything
I'm like
because he always says top 20 lines fool
you're 15. he would always say you're
15. I go John
try and
shut up and for like three years he did
he wouldn't and then one day I'm like
you want to try a line he just said [__]
it and I remember I was like I created a
monster the first time he did it I heard
his head came up and the smile he had I
went no you're hooked I felt bad but it
was like a friendly one we're not
sitting here
hey was anybody in either dick suck for
some [__] drugs no it was never like
that you were Fina now no but there's I
mean I can tell you a time where it was
in the middle of the night I'm like bro
I have no more drugs that sucks
hmm I would give all the weed I have
that's how far I'd go like I'd give all
the weed I have right now
and I love weed so that's not good
um
but the crack thing he bought a sack on
his own of crack no of coke on his own
yeah and I was like hey that's a little
different you buy it on your own you're
not just doing it with me yeah you got a
sack oh no because he knew my connect me
like four blocks from him
and then I remember he's like put it on
the ball and go I hate that [__] my
friends do that I don't like it it
tastes nasty I don't want to smoke Coke
on my weed like
do this to do this no thanks I like
roller coasters okay I'm good
and uh he put it on he smoked it and he
went oh come on man
I don't know I was smoking it right when
I hit it
I hit it and then it smelled like
colored crowns burning Jesus like Wax
burning yeah like but
I smelled it in here
I didn't just smell like that in my head
I'm not even sure that's the proper way
to do crack because I think you just
smoked you just smoked it wasn't
re-rocked or anything no no no so as I'm
smoking I'm like oh gross this tastes
disgusting I'm like give me let me see
it and that's when I went are you
[__] stupid and that's when I went
this isn't cocaine
he bought like 40 50 and it was rocked
up it was yellow and a ball chops and
shards yeah like like like when soap
starts to flake off of your bar of soap
when you're a kid right so it was quick
it was [__] crack with like they went
here's some coke and they just dusted it
wow they [__]
all right I looked at him like are you
[__] stupid so you didn't hit it and
you weren't like this is the greatest
[__] ever no I hit it I was like this
tastes like [__] and then I got a really
really bad headache
like uh one of these yeah like my head
was getting bigger than my head was and
I felt kind of like shaky or I just felt
wobbly and that's why I'm like give me
that let me let me see that [__] and
then we looked at it by lighter light or
the [__] you know what I mean and it was
yellow little ball crunches like
I don't know how to describe it you know
what crack looks like yeah they look
like crack from I see from the movies
and I went John for real
this is disgusting we're crackheads now
I hated it I'm glad I hated it though
like I tried oxy one time because John
my
dealer John okay not your uncle he was
stuck on oxy's bad this is obviously way
early in the in the game I'm assuming
fentanyl hadn't ruined a lot of people's
it was real bad the oxy [__] was crazy
she was crazy though he was popping them
like [__] Skittles bro it was really
really sad like it got to the point
where me and him were chilling every day
and I didn't really chill with my homie
that was his brother anymore because he
was like working doing like I'll chill
with your brother I'm getting packed
from anyway
and it was just sad man because he's
such a good guy he's such a nice dude
like he could do anything he [__]
wanted six two blonde hair blue eyes
like you have to world at your palm fool
come on he just kept getting into
[__] with little gang bangers and he
kept getting into [__] with the Oxys
and I remember there got to a time where
he was so [__] up
where he wouldn't stop answering and he
wouldn't remember what I owed him um and
I'm like I owe you that money oh yeah
yeah what did you take again and in my
head I'm like I could tell you two
pounds you gave me 20 piece oh wow I
could tell you anything right and you'd
be like oh God I'm not a piece of [__]
and I love that fool he's a gen like he
you know what I'm saying he's a good
person
and uh I remember I walked in once
and he was passed out like on the floor
partially on the couch there was like 60
peas laid out right in his walkway of
the house and the door is unlocked and I
just thought like what the [__] what the
[__] dude you know what I I could just
take it you're lucky it's me who came in
that's what I told him when I woke his
ass up like dude it's lucky you you're
lucky it's me somebody else would have
pulled up to try to see him they didn't
[__] ate yep and he almost [__]
Shot Me One Time by accident he was
asleep on the couch with this little
pistol when he was going through the
gangbanger [__]
and I knocked for 48 minutes straight I
needed the packs I'm like I'm just gonna
open the door and I yelled I yelled his
real name and he just went
and kind of like and I just kind of Dove
out the way a little into his kitchen
and I told him like I can't hang out
with you don't worry I stopped hanging
out with him like bro you could have
killed me Jesus come on and then um
the last time I talked to him he got
robbed at a party why why why would you
bring 30ps to a party I was so mad I was
like his Handler for a while but like
how old is this guy he's three years
older than me okay not much older yeah
but uh that was it it was the last time
I ever talked to him he [__]
disappeared that night after he got
robbed
that pajer's little puppy he just got
his little puppy and they found his
puppy shot on the road oh [__] right
outside of town
and then
that's it I don't know what happened I
mean I know what happened a little
but he's been gone for like nine years
nowadays [__] Irma's mom was putting
like missing poster signs and [__] it
was really sad actually it sucks it was
sad dude like it was really bad he's
still gone damn missing still
like two years ago someone said that
they found a body buried like outside of
town they're like could it be so and so
they kind of matches the age and [__]
I'm like [__] dude just tell me if it is
or not right you know are you still
friends with his little brother uh uh if
I got like eight homies six of them live
outside what type of [__] they're all
tweaking now so it's like oh it's like
when you say six of them I'll say like
they're homeless yeah yeah they live
outside oh [__] and uh in Merced in
Merced yeah I try to help his ass yeah
it just didn't work dude